Long before Kim Jong own became the goto tyrants for five star absurdity.
There was another dictator on the block.
Muammar Gaddafi,
rude,
Libya for 42 years with an iron fist,
wraps in a sequin the glove,
so garish,
it would put liberace to shame his flamboyant rain.
It was famous for its absurdity for every headline relating to his terrorist
activities.
There were maybe a dozen more about his plastic surgery addiction or his old
female bodyguard treat.
By the time Gaddafi was overthrown in 2011,
he was less fit than he was simply mocked,
but behind the monstrous vanity lay,
a man who was simply a month staff rape and Gaddafi's Libya.
It was institutionalized.
Mass executions were broadcast on TV.
Dissidence were executed,
and their bodies were kept in freezers.
For these self-styled King of all kings to visit.
It is leisure,
but such depraved behavior.
It wasn't created in a vacuum.
It was only thanks to Libya's tortured history.
There's good offi was able to imprint his psychosis on his nation.
Today on biographics,
we're exploring the life of the mad dog of the Middle East.
Most historians of Gaddafi start with the obvious place,
the sweltering and June day in 1942 when he was born in a nomads,
tends near the dusty fishing village of Santa Fe.
But to really understand Gaddafi,
you have to go back further all the way.